I could watch game tape or 07 Pats
highlights do your
job Raiders have a mascot I can't get
anything to work it's so creepy up close
sever him Raider rusher this is just
disgusting fan
service anything but the $40
million oh
yeah all I have to do is sit in this hot
seat and split my focus equally this is
too easy or I could give Tyler alir all
the looks coach coach a scary mascot is
coming for
you they say mascots come alive and take
out coaches on the hot seat that's just
a myth like the boogeyman or the
divisional round plus we don't even have
a mascot every team has a mascot at ease
major tuty Commander outranks Major and
as your commanding officer I said stand
down I have nothing to fear but Captain
fear himself ah unibrow matches his
mustache ah look out it's Staley oh
thank you I do think we're a bit of a
scary team not you Staley de be sorry I
don't know you're confusing lore help he
looks sleepy but he's
not where's the deadbolt the only dead
bolt is you you're not even team
approved hey with your size maybe I can
start you a tight end they wanted me to
sit on that Hot Seat but I have more
security than
anyone eventually we will have to take
him out my bigheaded
[Music]
friend yeah coach Tomlin I told you want
to me down from the
booth wait that magnificent chin that
beautiful American made ibeam oh God
it's stealing
m